fat joe and who else um
khaled dj khaled made an only fans
together
what is it i i saw the funniest retweet
who would want to watch these two [ __ ]
each other
what do you think it is it's just jet
ski videos like videos of them just
cruising on jet skis all day this this
cal it's just a place for khaled to post
his jet ski videos but not worry about
his his swim trunks coming down the top
of his crack
he's tired of being censored on
instagram for the top of his crack show
when he does his jet ski videos
yeah i mean they just don't make shorts
on the right size you know yeah
you know it's not his bad it's not yeah
he should be able to show a little crack
on the internet
you know snapchat keeps [ __ ] him they
keep taking him off deleting his snaps
the world needs to see his jet ski
videos
yeah okay people need to see cal it's
correct seriously though what is it
do we know um i
did what the [ __ ] was that somewhere in
the fridge
yeah no i got to i found i found the
world's last dinosaur
and i just chained his ass to to my
to a bike rack i drilled a bike rack
into my concrete backyard and i chained
him up to it and then he's just
angry he sounds angry yeah peta come and
get this dinosaur
yeah yeah pull it up i want to see let's
see because you know what's funny
is i was uh i was doing research for
another video and i
went back and i was looking at um do you
remember that kid we reacted to for
that's cringe
he was the kid on sixth street that used
to like hit on girls named jack manley
yeah remember that and i went back to
history because i'm like i was watching
newer content like there's a lot of
content like that on tick tock
people like do tons of main on the
street content yeah yeah 90
is just [ __ ] garbage would you let me
[ __ ] you in your in your butt for yeah
yes exactly like what's your body count
and they say something then they go
like the reaction every single time is
oh
that's that's what they do they turn to
the camera they go what
and uh anyways i go to jack manley's
twitter and he's got like an exclusive
content link or whatever and he's got an
only fans
oh nice and then do you remember that
dude nerd baller
nerd baller let me let me let me look
him up maybe if i see his face
he is the guy he also did [ __ ] on sixth
street but he was like
same sort of thing oh yeah this dude how
much money to see your titties but then
the money was fake yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he has a patreon he
makes 50k
a month doing like porn basically now
a girl's like just flashing so they're
just doing girls gone wild
yes pretty much but i i so that
that okay i see a use case for only fans
there but what the [ __ ] is fat joe and
dj khaled going to do
it okay it says here it says welcome to
the this is the description for their
only fans
welcome to the light the page for fans
to get exclusive motivational and
inspirational content
where we will be guiding fans to the
light while sharing uplifting insights
and behind the scenes of our personal
lives so it's just a
this is like clarissa yeah so it's a
blog
yeah basically just a gratitude
journaling blog
it's a vlog but
there's already a like someone already
did this
let's do tony robbins yeah then i've
already got this
figured out and it's 20 bucks a month
damn man yeah we should definitely
subscribe on the company card to see
what the [ __ ] this
is we should do it we should do it yeah
we should do it can you do it right now
oh [ __ ] we paid what we paid 20 bucks
for one video
all right all right what do you think
we've we've now gone through their
entire
hands there's definitely balls okay this
ball is for sure
balls involved nice nice
all right how many two exactly
there are two balls involved with the
basketball and fat joe's head
yeah no they had two different they used
two different basketballs
okay yeah so the so we spent about two
two minutes going through their their
whole only fans there's one post right
now
and it's a trailer for their basketball
game that they're gonna play against
each other
one on one and it's only on only fans
what the [ __ ]
that's it like you think if you're
starting a [ __ ] only fans you'd
spend a little time beefing it up with
some content like even just pictures of
you sitting around like
something have something there so that
when people pay 20 bucks they're not
like oh that's
that's it yeah we just got a little bit
scammed
yeah that's so strange man
although that being said i kind of am
excited to watch the basketball game
i just don't know who's waiting who's
been waiting to
see this rematch they they say it's a
rematch i don't even know it's the first
one
yeah like when did the first one
where what's the first one on is that on
youtube or something
let's see khaled verse fat joe
basketball
i'm not seeing
yeah i'm not seeing anything no you
don't see anything
maybe maybe they did it on snapchat or
something like that maybe it was
an exclusive okay on august 21st this is
on facebook
it's just it's just what we just saw
this is them playing basketball on what
on youtube
on facebook on facebook okay exactly and
how many views how many views
have this is a hip-hop
column site uh okay damn bro so you
telling me
they're making people pay twenty dollars
for free content
like this is the let's see that let's
see the facebook video here
here he's got it he's got it i will link
it
amazing
yes [ __ ] okay so this is from
august of this year last year
last year sorry last year forgot it's 20
21.
some boy i make tuna go pop my like us
make soon i go pop natural pop in your
bum buck
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that was it that's it it's just
it's replaying now what the [ __ ] popping
a boomba cloud
what the [ __ ] i mean he's trying to
speak you know
he's doing the that's why yeah he's in
the chat
he's doing the chat hanks no chet hangs
is better at it than him
i mean look
i just what this is the worst thing to
bring to only fans a basketball
one-on-one
the funniest thing is they use that
footage they just re-cut it and put
music behind it
yeah it's the exact same thing we got we
got scammed brother
how many people you think signed up for
that two
two people just me and you
[Laughter]
oh my god it's like to think we could
use that money to buy something better
gear from sweetwater from sweetwater
dude i'm i'm just you know
i'm just taking back like they're
they're not even they're not even
playing the game
but it's not like there are naked
you know what i mean yeah it's just it's
not like there's
like virgin basketball
pg two big boys playing ball
which is maybe is a like obscure fetish
yeah maybe yeah the same way tiger
capitalized on his like old leaked nudes
maybe their management
said hey guys that video of you guys
playing basketball
it sparked a whole new subculture yeah
and it is growing i don't know what it
is but i've seen
there's a subreddit now it's wild
there's a there's a
tick tock community i mean it's going up
triple b big boy ball and if we could
just get the two of you
to pave the way because then we start
getting another then we can start
involving other big boys playing the
game okay we can get rod wave
get a three-way game of you the three of
you
versus garth brooks versus khaled and
garth
here's the catch it's every man for
themself
yeah okay yeah so it's it's like a
regular high school
junior high school game four of you
fighting for one ball
i was gonna do numbers i'll tell you
what
you